estas navidades de 2021 vamos a celebrar
un aniversario muy especial se cumplen
30 años de la caída del comunismo en la
unión soviética habéis oído bien el 25
de diciembre de 1991 el por entonces
presidente de la unión soviética mijail
gorbachov dio este discurso igual si me
niegas a drogba gast de yuma delante me
voy a
ayudar a tener a gente extraña presiona
de la red y
esto es a dejarles carta magna ver
creciste septiembre del
el cardinal no se humilla en este
discurso no solo anunciaba su dimisión
también anunciaba la desintegración de
la unión soviética y el fin del
socialismo real no sé si os dais cuenta
de la importancia de este momento pero
esto es algo así como si mañana llega el
papá y dice que se ha vuelto ateo
podemos decir que el comunismo en rusia
no cayó por una revuelta popular ni
tampoco por una guerra fue el propio
líder comunista el que un día dijo
chicos nos hemos dado cuenta de que esto
no funciona y que nos tenemos que hacer
capitalistas a la feliz navidades muchos
diréis pues menuda novedad en la que no
se veía venir pero lo cierto es que
hasta ese momento la unión soviética era
la segunda potencia más importante del
mundo y ni siquiera los más fervientes
anti comunistas se habrían imaginado que
el comunismo o el socialismo real fuera
a caer por su propio peso así que la
pregunta es por qué cayó el comunismo en
la unión soviética en este vídeo te lo
vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
problema soviética es cómo tus
bisabuelos posiblemente te han contado
muchas cosas sobre ellos pero en
realidad no los has conocido o apenas
tiene recuerdos de ellos pues colonia en
soviética pasa lo mismo todos sabemos
que tenían un sistema comunista que a
ganaron en la segunda guerra mundial y
que después empezaron una guerra fría
con eeuu y en general con el mundo
capitalista sin embargo estos días se
cumplen nada menos que 30 años de la
disolución de la unión soviética y hace
sólo un mes vimos un tweet de bloomberg
con una frase del presidente chino que
nos llamó muchísimo la atención si
asegura que la unión soviética cayó
porque nadie fue lo suficientemente
hombre para levantarse y resistir a eeuu
vale sabíamos que lorgio soviética había
escasez de muchas cosas pero seamos
honestos la testosterona no era una de
ellas básicamente porque todos los que
mandaban eran hombres en cualquier caso
así se pronunció xi jinping en el año
2012 en un discurso meses antes de
convertirse en presidente de chiná así
que nos han entrado aquí en visual
político muchas ganas de hablar de la
unión soviética porque pues porque
queremos hacer un balance de lo que fue
el comunismo soviético reconocer sus
logros que también los hubo y señalar
sus errores por supuesto en este vídeo
vamos a resumir de 80 años de historia
en sólo unos pocos minutos así que por
supuesto que habrá muchos detalles que
no vamos a poder cubrir y por eso hoy
vamos a centrarnos en una única pregunta
por qué cayó el comunismo que ocurrió
para que el 25 de diciembre de 1991 el
líder de una de las mayores
superpotencias del mundo dimitiera y
anunciara todo un cambio de sistema
político por qué motivo fracasaron las
reformas de gorbachov hoy en visual
político vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
nacimiento de una superpotencia
[Música]
en el año 1929 eeuu sufría la gran
depresión y mientras todo el mundo
capitalista estaba inmerso en una crisis
económica salvaje el este comunista
estaba en su edad de oro habéis oído
bien rusia estaba pasando de ser un país
casi medieval y agrícola a convertirse
en toda una potencia industrial y de
hecho hay estimaciones que dicen que la
unión soviética era uno de los países
que más rápido estaban creciendo en todo
el mundo y si digo estimaciones porque
el pib no se empezó a utilizar como
indicador macroeconómico hasta el año
1937 pero eso es otra historia lo
importante es que rusia estaba on fire
y diréis pero como es esto posible no se
supone que el comunismo no funciona
pensadlo bien hay algo mucho peor que el
comunismo y eso es la falta de sistema
hasta la revolución rusa los zares se
limitaban a enlazar una guerra con otra
y para financiarla se dedicaban a
imprimir rublos ya exprimir a sus
súbditos recaudando impuestos de repente
llegan los comunistas y el estado
empieza a utilizar todo ese dinero que
recauda para invertir así es como los
rusos empezaron a tener educación
infraestructuras y sistemas de
producción más modernos el centralismo
económico transfirió recursos del campo
a las ciudades
los soviéticos creían que la
industrialización tenía que hacerse a
gran escala para tener éxito la
producción de las fábricas debía ser lo
suficientemente grande como para
justificar el alto coste inicial de
construirlas por eso tras el primer plan
quinquenal de stalin en el año 1928 el
capital invertido en industrializar el
país aumentó en un
336 por ciento la cantidad de campesinos
expulsados de las granjas e incorporados
a la industria creció en casi un 190 por
ciento todo esto cosechó buenos
resultados aunque ligeramente por debajo
de lo esperado la producción industrial
creció un 170 por ciento
stalin podríamos decir que decía lo
mismo que en parque jurásico no hemos
reparado en gastos luego ya llegaron los
dinosaurios pero de momento hay que ver
cómo lucía el parque soviético eso sí un
problema grave es que la colectivización
agrícola no termino de funcionar stalin
trató de extraer recursos de la
agricultura por la fuerza ya que yo fue
un desastre acabó con los kulaks que
eran los agricultores más prósperos y
nacionalizó los animales de tiro lo que
provocó que fueran sacrificados por los
granjeros
[Música]
el resultado habla por sí solo la
producción agrícola disminuyó en más de
una cuarta parte en comparación con 1928
pero stalin no era precisamente esa
clase de gobernantes que tolera la
crítica como todos ya sabéis la
represión en estos años fue terrible el
principal periódico soviético dice que
20 millones murieron como víctimas de
stalin y lo peor de los años 30 es que
eras un don nadie si no invadía xa otro
país así que esta ley le pareció muy
buena idea firmar el pacto
molotov-ribbentrop con la alemania nazi
para repartirse la mitad de polonia
anexionarse las repúblicas bálticas y
ocupar besara es la actual moldavia
luego hitler de tradicional y casi casi
acaba con la unión soviética porque
estas alturas stalin había hecho una
purga brutal dentro del ejército rojo
liquidando a prácticamente todos los
altos mandos finalmente la victoria de
la segunda guerra mundial confirmó a la
unión soviética como una de las dos
grandes superpotencias del globo y así
es como empezaba la guerra fría
en la cima al colapso
seguro que todos lo habréis oído alguna
vez el comunismo soviético no funcionaba
porque la gente no tenía incentivos para
trabajar es esto cierto pues sí pero a
la vez no si seguís nuestro canal
hermano mega project ya conocéis muchos
de los grandes avances soviéticos la
unión soviética podía presumir de tener
a muchas de las mentes más brillantes de
la historia de hecho durante los
primeros años de la carrera espacial
rusia llevaba bastante ventaja a los
eeuu es más por aquel entonces se tenía
en occidente una sensación parecida a la
que hoy en día se tiene con china había
un miedo real a que los soviéticos
superasen económicamente y sobre todo
militarmente a los eeuu y en general al
mundo capitalista
pensadlo bien apenas había información
sobre lo que ocurría al otro lado del
telón de acero y el aparato de censura
soviéticos se encargaba muy bien de
tapar sus vergüenzas y lo cierto es que
cada vez había más vergüenzas que
taparon podríamos decir que a mediados
de los años 60 es cuando el comunismo
soviético empieza a agotarse
por supuesto la aparición del petróleo
en siberia ofreció un pequeño respiro al
partido comunista en cualquier caso el
problema de la economía soviética es que
tenía una productividad muy reducida la
unión soviética se estaba quedando
estancada en los años 70 y diréis pero
porque dónde está el problema y aquí es
donde entra en escena uno de los pocos
economistas que sí predijeron el colapso
del comunismo soviético y lo hizo varias
décadas antes de que ocurriera hablamos
del ludwig von mises en su obra el
socialismo misses explica las
principales diferencias entre una
economía centralizada y una economía
libre
[Música]
y veréis en una economía libre los
empresarios encuentran ineficiencias que
intentan resolver algunos acierta y se
hacen ricos y otras fracasan y
desaparecen pero en general el capital
tiende a concentrarse en los sectores
más eficientes y cómo se sabe cuáles son
los sectores más eficientes pues
mediante el sistema de precios si yo veo
que el precio de un bien es muy alto en
x mercado es porque existe mucha demanda
de ese bien es decir que hace falta en
una economía centralizada el capital no
se reparte bajo criterios económicos
sino políticos es decir el estado puede
invertir en sectores que no
necesariamente son los más eficientes
eso explica que un régimen socialista
pueda tener éxito en el corto plazo
porque pues porque el estado gasta a
manos llenas y puede incluso crear
sectores que de otro modo serían
impensables queréis un ejemplo industria
pesada en un país como rusia que venía
de ser un país agrícola el problema es
que a la larga empiezan a surgir
deficiencias que no se detectan porque
no hay ni competencia ni exigencia real
de responsabilidades queréis un ejemplo
pues os voy a dar un ejemplo el de la
historia del mar de aral
el mar de aral era antiguamente uno de
los cuatro lagos más grandes de todo el
planeta tierra en los años sesenta la
unión soviética hizo un montón de
trasvases para llevar toda esa agua a
los campos de cultivo de algodón todo
esto habría sido prácticamente imposible
de hacer en un país capitalista porque
pues porque el estado habría tenido que
pasarse años de litigios para hacerse
con todas las propiedades y el precio de
todos estos terrenos sería tan caro que
al final se habrían podido hacer sólo
unos pequeños trasvase sin embargo en un
país comunista como la unión soviética
no existe propiedad privada sobre la
tierra así que alguien en una oficina de
moscú decidió que había que hacer un
mega trasvase de un día para otro y de
repente el lago quede reducido a un 10
por ciento de su tamaño original además
del desastre ecológico que todo esto
supone también hay un desastre económico
porque lo que podría ser una zona
perfecta para el cultivo a largo plazo
ahora se ha convertido en un desierto
pues bien ahora imaginad este ejemplo
replicado en mil y un casos más la
historia de la unión soviética es la
historia de montones de proyectos
megalómanos ciudades como magnitogorsk
de la que hablamos en megaproyectos que
fueron creadas de un día para otro por
supuesto muchos de estos proyectos no
tenían por qué ser malas ideas
inicialmente el problema es que al no
tener un sistema de precios no se sabía
cuántos recursos había que invertir para
que realmente tuvieran un sentido
económico si a todo esto le sumamos la
falta de libertad de expresión tenemos
que nadie se atrevía a señalar a las
ineficiencias conclusión pues lo que en
un momento fue una de las economías de
más rápido crecimiento del mundo termino
estancándose
[Aplausos]
la crisis del petróleo de 1979 disparó
el precio del crudo lo que volvió a
inyectar montones y montones de dólares
a la economía soviética pero esto hizo
que el politburó se viniera arriba y
alguien del kremlin le pareciera una
buena idea invadir afganistán hoy en día
ya sabemos que incursionar por kabul y
alrededores es ir directos al precipicio
y los soviéticos tampoco se escaparon de
la trampa al cama de repente se vieron
envueltos en una espiral continua de
aumento del gasto militar pero ojo que
la culpa no fue sólo de los órganos
ronald reagan en eeuu también tuvo mucho
que ver
mentiras y pruebas manipuladas de
starwars engañaron al kremlin y al
congreso no era tan potente como la
estrella de la muerte pero reagan se
sacó de la manga todo un escudo espacial
para protegerse de un potencial ataque
nuclear que desató el pánico en el
kremlin los dirigentes comunistas se
pusieron a gastar millones y millones en
intentar replicar algo que es
sencillamente era imposible porque no
era más que una burla estadounidense
esta estafa supuso la ruina absoluta
para la economía de la unión soviética
estaba clara la cuestión que tenían
sobre la mesa hasta qué punto era
demasiado tarde para intentar cambiar un
moderno la unión soviética pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
la perestroika
la unión soviética llegó a los años 80
con la 'vieja guardia' los mandos se
había convertido en toda una
gerontocracia la edad promedio de los
miembros del politburó era de 70 años
frente a los 55 que tenían cuando murió
stalin y hombre pues sí es verdad que la
experiencia es un grado pero también
tiene sus riesgos en menos de tres años
murieron tres secretarios generales del
partido comunista bréznev andrópov y
chernienko el régimen daba muestras de
descomposición
no
la corrupción asolaba al kremlin se
acaba de descubrir el gran escándalo del
algodón que implicaba directamente a uno
de los peces gordos del politburó no era
un caso aislado los escándalos de los
dirigentes comunistas ya no los podía
tapar ni la peor censura
así que los reformistas estaban cargados
de razones cuando en 1985 consiguieron
la designación de mijail gorbachov como
máximo dirigente de la unión soviética
visto lo visto era todo un chaval solo
tenía 54 años y muchas ganas de cambiar
las cosas y trató de hacerlo desde el
principio pero en seguida sus reformas
tuvieron que hacer frente a la gran
prueba de fuego el peor accidente
nuclear de la historia
[Música]
chernóbil dejo una vez más en evidencia
la falta de transparencia de las
autoridades soviéticas y unos años
después de la catástrofe el propio
corbacho lo tenía claro el accidente
nuclear de chernóbil incluso más que mi
lanzamiento de la perestroika fue quizás
la principal causa del colapso de la
unión soviética cinco años después
mijail gorbachov abril de 2006 el
encubrimiento de chernóbil fue letal
para la unión soviética las autoridades
soviéticas tardaron varios días en
informar del accidente por miedo los
primeros datos de la catástrofe llegarán
desde suecia donde se detectó un aumento
de la radioactividad así que la gente de
ucrania y del resto de europa del este-
estuvo haciendo vida normal sin saber
que se estaban exponiendo a lo peor de
la nube radioactiva aquello fue para
gorbachov una muestra de que el sistema
soviético necesitaba reformas más
profundas que las ya iniciadas y todas
estas reformas se hicieron bajo la
bandera de la perestroika que en ruso
significa reestructuración
en globo un conjunto de medidas
diseñadas para liberalizar poco a poco
la economía y el sistema político se
dieron pasos hacia un mercado libre e
ilimitado y hacia cierta
descentralización de la economía
soviética una parte importante de estas
reformas fueron la glasnot que significa
transparencia la prensa y la televisión
empezaron a incluir posturas contrarias
al proyecto socialista y todo esto
condujo a celebrar en 1989 unas
elecciones relativamente libres que
dejaron claramente en evidencia que el
partido comunista estaba completamente
desacreditado ante los ciudadanos los
votantes soviéticos ofrecen un golpe
humillante a los candidatos oficiales
del partido la caída del muro de berlín
a finales de 1989 fue el primer signo de
que todo el bloque comunista empezaba a
desmoronarse a lo largo de 1990 se
celebraron elecciones legislativas en
cada una de las 15 repúblicas
socialistas soviéticas por primera vez
la oposición al kremlin tenía libertad
para poder decir lo que el politburó del
partido comunista no quería escuchar y
así es como llegó la oportunidad que los
nacionalistas de cada una de las
repúblicas estaban esperando
las tres repúblicas bálticas estonia
letonia y vitoria no perdieron ni un
segundo para iniciar su transición a la
independencia otros territorios también
reivindicaban su propia soberanía como
la propia república soviética rusa
liderada por policial sin la
desintegración de la unión soviética
había iniciado su cuenta atrás todo se
celebró en agosto de 1991 con el fallido
golpe de estado dado por la caja y el
ala dura del partido comunista ya no
había vuelta atrás las repúblicas
socialistas soviéticas decidieron acabar
con la unión soviética así que en su
discurso de renuncia como presidente de
la urss gorbachov expuso el fracaso
absoluto del comunismo de wong símil y
niegas a draghi freedom edwards de una
delantera del avión pueda jugar
temporadas de textron a prisión a de la
serna y
dejarles tienes que amar porque este
sistema tag de gerry bell en el ser
nada de la cardenal se humilla
[Música]
desmantelar la unión soviética era lo
último en lo que pensaba gorbachov él
creía que el régimen comunista podía
avanzar hacia una especie de
socialdemocracia que contará con el
apoyo de la gente pero después de
décadas bajo el yugo del poder soviético
cuando a la gente le das la oportunidad
de pronunciarse el lo único que quieren
es algo muy sencillo quieren libertad
[Música]
la verdad era simple la unión soviética
era imposible de reformar el 25 de
diciembre de 1991 su bandera era arriada
en el kremlin punto final para la hoz y
el martillo en su lugar empezó a ondear
la bandera tricolor de la federación
rusa
y ahora muchos os preguntaréis pero y
qué pasó después de verdad leído bien a
rusia con el capitalismo pues no está
del todo claro la verdad pero de todo
eso vamos a hablar en otro vídeo que
sacaremos próximamente mientras tanto la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que la
unión soviética podría haber evitado su
disolución y lo que es más importante
qué pensáis de gorbachov de verdad
creéis que fue un héroe de la democracia
como muchos le quieren poner o tal vez
fue simplemente una víctima de los
acontecimientos podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y por
supuesto no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a este canal
y donde la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
también quiero recordaros que tenemos un
canal hermano que se llama mega
proyectos con acá de visual político
donde hablamos de un montón de estos
proyectos que dieron la sal y la vida a
la unión y que seguro que a muchos de
vosotros os van a interesar si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]